[Music]
uh hello plastic pills listeners this is
victor i'm with uh matt mcmanus and new
to the podcast jordan de jeong who is a
phd student at the university of ottawa
we're here to talk about uh a new book
well i guess it's not that new right it
was recently translated into english
about nietzsche it's called nietzsche
the aristocratic rebel
intellectual biography and critical
balance sheet by
dominic leserto
and matt and jordan just spent the last
couple weeks reading it it's like a
thousand pages um i did not read it
because i have better things to do with
my time
um i have to write a dissertation and
yeah i just i'm not gonna spend a
thousand uh pages on nietzsche right now
but i am here just to sort of moderate
the discussion a little bit because you
know both of these people are actually
like two of my best friends but one of
the things about them is they're both
extremely long-winded both of them
and i have to be here to rein them in
basically uh and make sure you know
pills sent me to reign them in because
they're both long-winded so i got to
make sure that the conversation keeps
going
and uh things don't get out of control
here and that it's actually listenable
so
here we go i don't know maybe one of you
why don't you start tell me what the
basic thesis of the book from what i
read i did read matt you have like a
review maybe it's out maybe it's coming
out soon
but like it sounds like it's sort of in
the same vein as
uh professor ronald [ __ ] at the
university of toronto's book at least in
so far as it's kind of painting
nietzsche to be a bit more have more
reactionary potential
um than maybe the more existentialist
readings the more egalitarian and sort
of like post-structuralist uh in
engagements with nietzsche what have you
believe uh so yeah i don't know we could
start there if one of you wants to jump
in
to say a bit more reactionary potential
is to very much understate
is it
yeah
okay yeah but maybe um matt you go ahead
yeah absolutely i mean
it is it absolutely does invite
comparisons to being his book also
malcolm bulls and book uh auntie
nietzsche uh nancy loves take i mean
anyone who's concerned with the kind of
political implications of nietzsche's
thought in the 21st century uh except
the thing is as victor mentioned if
bienner's book is kind of like a really
tasty appetizer you know you could think
of like a fantastic you know chicory
plate this is like a [ __ ] feast in
the sense that it's almost too much uh
like victor mentioned it's a thousand
pages more really if you add the
impedance footnotes bibliography and all
that stuff uh and it's really the work
of a lifetime of scholarship just
dedicated to challenging uh what
luceroto calls the hermeneutics of
innocence right this belief that
nietzsche either isn't a very political
thinker and the philosophical germ of
his thought can be extracted from the
kind of variable political comments he
makes uh or if he is a political thinker
he's kind of a bohemian liberal
committed to this idea of free spirits
and joyful sciences uh and kind of
self-creation that's kind of the reading
that the existentialists give him right
like a lot of times and like what's his
name kaufman i think is kind of like uh
notorious for being kind of like the the
sort of like head in the
english-speaking world of like the
hermeneutics of uh innocence would you
say or yeah absolutely so i just i
distinguished three periods in the
review uh which is coming out at some
point with philosophy now but not for a
year because they're backlogged um the
last story short there's kind of three
periods to nietzsche's scholarship that
i trace in the review and maybe we can
start there
because it really informs the kind of
hermeneutics of innocence that's the
main thesis of the book uh where you
know lucero points out that initially uh
nietzsche was kind of unknown so i guess
there's really four periods uh but then
later in his life he became actually
quite famous particularly in reactionary
political circles um
in continental europe right and you can
think of his reception uh for fascism uh
you could think of the reception by a
lot of nazi figures and this led many
people in the anglo-american world
particularly bertrand russell right
infamously uh to just dismiss him as
either a hacker a german nationalist or
a militarist or a proto-nazi
and then along comes the second
interpretation by people like kaufman
the existential interpretation that's
much more charitable and that points out
that nietzsche held many
anti-nazi views uh right and that is
wrong to just kind of
denigrate him
as a proto-fascist or a proto-nazi since
a lot of thought is vastly more
interesting
and resists that kind of interpretation
and it's also true right that the actual
existentialists just to sort of set the
historical stage like before because
kaufman i'm actually not certain what
kaufman's sort of like chronological
time period is but he's like the second
half of the 20th century
yeah absolutely okay so
so before him
certainly in the first half of the 20th
century there were in fact
existentialists who were taking up
nietzsche like right i mean heidegger
it's arguable whether you'd include them
but like weren't people like sartre no
for sure
absolutely
yeah but yeah but it's arguable whether
you would include him in the in the sort
of like bread and butter existentialism
some people do some people like i mean
he was certainly an inspiration right
right but he's not necessarily like in
the same
he's not as closely linked i think as
the other existential phenomenologists
like uh and they all i think draw
nietzsche right and all of them have
sort of egalitarian political visions so
i don't know absolutely so that there
was this kind of stream of left-wing uh
existentialism that emerged in france
hugely influenced by nietzsche uh and
along with copton that's did a great
deal to kind of exonerate nietzsche's um
you know kind of reputation uh in the
western world rightly so again because i
don't think the nazi interpretation is
right uh and lesotho for that matter
doesn't think it's right then you get to
the kind of third interpretation of him
uh which is not as a
proto-existentialist or as the father of
existentialism you know there's a debate
whether kierkegaard gets that title or
ninja but as a kind of
proto-post-structuralist right and that
everybody here should be familiar with
that you can think of i know eric has
mentioned you know the essay on truth
and lying on a non-moral sense where he
talks about truth as a moving army of
metaphors or the kind of genealogical
method of historical analysis pioneered
in the genealogy of morals very
influenced by foucault
and this is also a time period where
his work is kind of interpreted as
either being apolitical or it is
political it's about analysis of power
to try to liberate people from its
strictures right uh liberate people from
the strictures of coerciforms morality
and this would include people like deliz
right and and that's of interest to our
listeners because uh for some reason a
lot of our listeners love de las so
they're gonna be they're going to be
very resistant i'm guessing to to this
to this kind of line of argument that
that lacerdo is offering exactly you can
think about like deliza's classic book
on nietzsche right uh where he focuses a
great deal on creating healthy kinds of
personalities creative personalities
that's the niches somebody like the
lewis likes right same thing as the
nietzsche that somebody like foucault
likes uh is the genealogical critique of
power and morality right to create if
space is uh for an ethic of
self-creation as a leader calls it right
but now we're going to enter you into a
new phase where a lot of people are
revisiting this idea that maybe
nietzsche does actually held some
extremely reactionary views uh providing
textual support for it
and one of the big instigators for this
uh was of course the fact that many
people on the alt right or the far right
or however we want to characterize it
drew very heavily on certain nietzschean
themes to justify their positions uh and
now you have people like lucerto and
bull and [ __ ] coming along and saying
the nazi take is wrong absolutely but we
shouldn't be engaging in this project of
a hermeneutics of suspicion that tries
to imply that there was nothing in his
work that could lend itself to very
reactionary interpretations and lacerdo
i'd say is probably the most
comprehensive of these critics where he
says if you nietzsche did have a
politics which he did
it was
radically aristocratic and inegalitarian
so if you want to take his philosophy
and appropriate it for these egalitarian
causes that's fine but we should be very
cognizant of the fact that he himself
would be not just resistant to it uh but
extremely hostile to that idea great and
actually i do want to just quickly say
before i move to you jordan um
you know i love you delisian listeners
you know don't don't don't don't assume
my little snarky comment you know i just
liked a kid but um
yeah so that was that was very concise
no but i mean it's okay
i'm glad that you're giving a
comprehensive to set the stage for the
book but yeah i don't know jordan what
are your thoughts this book reminded me
of a passage that i came across in an
essay by stanley rosen
uh in written in the 1980s
and the essay is called nietzsche's
revolution
and it begins with this which i think
what just kind of will maybe restate
what we've been saying but he says uh
rosen says it is a remarkable fact that
nietzsche a self-professed decadent
nihilist atheist antichrist
opponent of academic philosophy scourge
of socialism egalitarianism and
the people
who espoused aristocratic political and
artistic views insisted upon a rank
ordering of human beings went as far as
to advise men to carry a whip when they
visit the women's quarters
is today one of the highest authorities
if not the authority for progressive
liberals existentialist theologians
professors
anarchist speculators
left-wing critics of the enlightenment
in bourgeois society for pounders of
egalitarianism and enemies of political
and artistic elitism he goes on and
won't even listen to them all i mean
that's pretty [ __ ] comprehensive yeah
yeah i thought so anyways i just thought
that so um just to say that this
topic or theme it has it was there
before um and then maybe i and i
sometimes wonder if rosen overstates his
case there that nietzsche is the kind of
he says that nietzsche is the most um
authoritative or important philosopher
in the non-marxist world yeah in the 80s
now i don't i don't know enough about
what was going on in intellectual trends
um
a question about that because what's
interesting i'm wondering whether this
is true you might know better jordan
than me but i know like rosen is kind of
like loosely associated with the
strozians and like it seems to me that
actually maybe i mean as much as you
know we've been critical in previous
times on this podcast at least the
strozians like i know that maybe they
were a bit more attuned to this reading
of nietzsche
or was that not correct i i think i
think that's i think that's definitely
correct the danger because of the
straussian approach they are more
attuned to
this um political dimension
because rosen occasionally does
um have interesting remarks about
marxists um
so
i think that
it provides a lot of space for for a
discussion um
whereas in other cases maybe the the
vaguely straussian inspired approaches
might have been
uh
discounted
um but i was curious jordan so like what
were your like general impressions of
the book after like a thousand pages did
you feel like you learned anything new
or or was it just kind of like all
nothing surprised here no i had well i
was
to begin with
i mean i i never uh had that i never
really had that phase where i thought of
nietzsche as um i never read him as a
progressive uh or progressively or um
in fact um that was that wasn't and that
wasn't even his excitement for me when i
first
started to read him probably because i
always have certain reactionary elements
in my own uh self uh from the beginning
and so which you know uh to clarify i
i i do find uh nietzsche's positions uh
disturbing and maybe
i i probably i i didn't uh confront when
i was younger the full import of um
of the sorts of things he was saying
like i had a professor once who said you
know when people read nietzsche they
always imagine that um they always
imagine that the last man is other
people
yeah right and and so i and i and i
think that's true and i think you know i
could not be a follower of you like
first of all for very selfish reasons
which is uh you know i would
according to him i think very much along
among those who should be consigned to
the uh
uh to destruction or whatever he is
whatever he would have planned but i
never thought of him really as um i
never really read him as uh as an
existentialist or a bohemian
or anything like that so this
um
with was just giving me more source
material um
for um
a view that was really consonant with
the view that i already had
that being said there some of the things
which were um
so he one of the things he does well is
he does situate nietzsche in um
in his environment in his milieu so that
some of the things which might appear to
you like especially like if you're young
and you've grown up in a in a hyper kind
of liberal climate and it's part of you
is reacting against that
or feels that there's something
constraining in that
then
uh nietzsche can
um
[Music]
like it's interesting actually because i
read matt i read your review of it you
were talking about how uh when you were
first read nietzsche you were
kind of intoxicated by the way that he
was speaking i mean who isn't right i
mean
it's kind of like you were saying i
think heidegger has this quality also
where
you read the book and it almost does
invite you to think of yourself as a
better person not better in the sense of
improving yourself but better really in
the sense that i am privy to some kind
of sacred profound insight into
existence and its problems that most
people do not have because they're
either inauthentic uh or because they
lack the will power to kind of see
things through to the utmost right and
that could be a very intoxicating kind
of attitude to have about yourself you
know when you're 18 years old or
whatever it happens to be right who
hasn't thought themselves you know the
world is all full of phonies except for
myself because obviously i'm better than
that right it's a very fatal conceit to
have and you should grow out of it but i
think we
anybody i know who's been that age
usually has at least some kind of period
where they go through something like
that right and nietzsche was one of the
catalysts for that for me and one of the
things i think that's interesting about
about nietzsche as um
in terms of what he says is you can read
nietzsche and you can become if you're
in a certain milieu you can be excited
by
uh you know that he proclaims the death
of god or
uh his attack on christianity or there
can be a whole certain set of pieties
which his uh
the attack that he he
um levies against them
can be intoxicating for you and but for
me it wasn't his attack on god that was
exciting it was actually
i suppose the
the
his attack on liberalism that excited me
like that that me like because at that
time and um
in my life i did feel kind of um
i don't know there were elements of like
i said that surrounding milieu or the
surrounding uh culture that i
was intentioned with for some reason or
another and so i i found him sort of
interesting on that score i that was my
first my my first experience of impiety
wasn't i was i i was already very i felt
very acquainted with impiety towards
christianity or something like that so
when it was against
um
the the
prevailing liberal culture that's kind
of what excited or interested me
when you say liberal culture like what
what do you mean by that because i think
like probably interestingly i think a
lot of the reason why like maybe some of
these leftist post-structuralists take
up nature at least part of the reason
is also because of his criticism of
liberalism right and actually i think
this actually goes more to the the heart
of the matter is just is um
is
people is is the criticism of what is
ultimately bourgeois
isn't
really solidly
um in the
uh belonging to the left or the right oh
yes there's something there's something
really politically ambiguous i guess
about the kind of about the critique of
law spirit and i think that nietzsche
has this like profound ability to
excite people who fall kind of on either
side of the conventional left uh right
divide and in fact in it it can be the
case that um
yeah people uh who are
maybe they have strong leftist
principles but everybody is uh
seduced by the image of
uh being the rebel or being
chosen
or
um
you know belonging to
some
regiment of
people who are secretly
kind of in the know or who spontaneously
live a life that is that is um
more in tune with something radical or
authentic and so yeah yeah i think that
um
sorry go ahead well i was going to move
it back to you anyway but i was just
going to say like so so
me i was thinking back to like the the
sort of title the subtitle of the book
about aristocratic rebel
um and just like based on what we were
talking about in terms of like these the
seductive aspects of nietzsche and how
he can be you know appealing to both the
left and the right but i guess i wonder
like
what this sort of like term
uh aristocratic like where that plays
into that because it seems to me that
maybe
what the left sometimes sees in
nietzsche like broadly speaking the left
is maybe like
someone like lucerto would think would
would argue that like oh they're kind of
like thinking
that everybody can have this
aristocratic spirit in the sense that
nietzsche can where like everybody can
become like freed of these structures
and like overcome
but like maybe the point that he's
making is like yeah like you're right
you're reading what he wants correctly
but like you're kind of ignoring the
parts when he says oh yeah but it's only
a couple people who are going to be able
to do this we're gonna be able to be
whereas like maybe the like most poor
post-structuralist reading is like oh no
everybody can be creative everybody can
be like self-overcoming and it's like
that's where and i wonder matt if like
like what you think about that or if
that seems right to you
yeah absolutely i don't think after you
read the book that there's any denying
that that's the way nietzsche actually
thought those were his political
convictions and he held to them very
strongly it might be
possible to appropriate elements of his
philosophical program or method and put
them to uh emancipatory purposes and i
think somebody like foucault does that
very successfully but then one of the
things that we should do is just be
honest that that's taking these
philosophical tools and putting them to
tasks that nietzsche himself would
fundamentally disagree with uh or even
think we're plausible down the line
right because the term aristocratic
rebel isn't lucerto's uh it was a friend
of nietzsche who wrote to him
and said this is the way that i would
characterize your work as this kind of
elitist radicalism uh this idea that the
problem with society isn't that we have
elites it's that the elites aren't
effective enough uh anichi agreed with
that interpretation right in fact he
said that's the best characterization of
my work i've heard thus far right so
he's very emphatic about this
and i want to point out that one of the
reasons why i think many people are
wary of endorsing this kind of position
is because a lot of people on the
political left really just don't spend a
lot of time reading conservative
literature right
and so the presumption as sheldon mullen
once put it is that conservatives are
just boring
stock defenders of the status quo
somebody like daddy for example you know
oh daddy and just for jordan who doesn't
know when we talk about daddy on this
podcast we mean jordan peterson yeah
okay
somebody who's just you know clean your
room
you know clean your room say nice things
to the cops and everything will be fine
right uh when really conservatism as a
defense of certain kinds of hierarchical
modes of thinking can be extremely
revolutionary or counter-revolutionary
depending on the circumstances or
radical as liserto puts it uh because
the kind of fundamental theme that comes
out of this book more strongly than
anything else uh is nietzsche believes
that the asean regime uh and the kind of
conservative elites in europe at his
time uh while he was attracted to them
early in the 1970s
he came to believe that they just
weren't tough enough to get the job done
uh putting liberalism and socialism back
in their place and so one of the things
that you needed was a much more creative
vibrant and indeed violent and militant
elite that would have the capacity and
the will power to actually accomplish
what the australian regime and
traditional conservative leads weren't
willing to do
right
and this is where the aristocratic
radicalism comes in right what he wanted
was a revolution against a kind of
bourgeois traditionalism uh or just
traditionalism
but it was a revolution that was
eventually going to put the right
hierarchy in place and keep everyone
else at the bottom and indeed created an
even more hierarchical society if that
was possible right
and that's a really fascinating idea
right it's a very very interesting idea
precisely because it runs so contrary to
what many people on the left expect when
they think about conservatism or the
forces of reaction uh but one of the
things that le cerdo brings up by
putting nietzsche into dialogue with
people like heidegger or schmidt
is that this was hardly an unusual
thought at the time right many of the
most creative thinkers on the right who
are extremely attractive today also held
to similar kind of convictions and
programs hmm yeah
that makes sense um
i don't know jordan what do you take up
when you think about this like this this
labeling of the aristocratic rebel i
mean i don't know is anything does that
resonate with you it's i find it very
it's very interesting you know i was i
saw somewhere on twitter the other day
somebody um made a post and it was
something like i'm so tired so tired in
leftist circles
of people who for whom it still accept
like oh no not leftist circles sorry he
said radical circles uh in radical
circles radical communities i'm so tired
of
of people where you know it there's
still uh
you know homophobia or transphobia or
racism or something like that right
and instead of a like a book like this
and other things you know one
um
your first reaction to that is yeah of
course right um but then you think well
how come radical
has this meaning how come radical has
this meaning that where there is
radicalism
there
there is egalitarianism exactly yeah
right and you know and and and
in order to um
well
yeah so nietzsche challenges i think
this idea that to be radical is to be
egalitarianism egalitarian but that's
also a kind of disturbing thought i
think for a lot of us
because um
well then what does it mean to be
what does it mean to be radical
right because it suggests like because
the presumption seems to be that if
we're radical
that means that we are truly
this is one possibility anyways maybe
there's other answers but one
possibility is if we are being radical
then we are really thinking things down
to the bottom
right
and if we're really thinking things down
to the bottom
we it will become evident to us
what the egalitarian
or um project should be like that that
that it will become evidence right and
so in some ways somebody like sunita
would be like you imagine nietzsche over
your shoulder there and saying like you
are kind of it's possible that you're
still presupposing this link between
inquiry
and truth
and
your your desired in a certain political
outcome and he raises this question like
i mean it kind of raises this question
what is modernity
um because because what i'll just add
one of the things that i thought that
the zerto in this book quite frequently
uh you know draws attention that
nietzsche's project is an anti-modern
project right
but
um
[Music]
but
or or in each's own words right but
if it's anti-but at the same time it
seems to be that these are equated that
to be anti-modern is to be
anti-egalitarian
so it raises this question is there
something about modernity
that is intrinsically
egalitarian
or
not
if modernity is not intrinsically
egalitarian then what uh if it is not
tending towards or if it doesn't have a
movement towards egalitarianism um kind
of of its nature as opposed to
contingent me then what is it and um and
i think in a book like this does uh help
us maybe think more about this question
about just like what is modernity and
what is radicalism and what are the link
between those and our
political uh
those are
those are great thoughts and actually
like i i i i kind of had a a related
thought when i was reading matt's review
of the book
because i think you're right that like
this assumption that radicalism means
uh you know egalitarianism seems faulty
but but but it is in the ether it's
almost become like a synonym for like
some sort of like leftist egalitarianism
when but it's interesting that you said
maybe it means like getting to some root
because like what my initial reaction to
the word radicalism is like about
novelty it's it's like some sort of
radical like opening up space for
something radically new
and like in my and that was what i was
thinking before you said getting to the
roots because i was like oh well like
yeah that new thing could be something
really egalitarian or could be some new
hierarchy it could be some new
you know aristocratic dispensation uh
right so like
um oh yeah so so that's
those were kind of my thoughts but yeah
matt i saw that you wanted to speak so
no no no i think that's a really good
point right and we're all hitting the
nail here because one of the things
that's really important that i thought
jordan expressed really well is there is
this presupposition on the part of the
left that radicalism has to be
associated with some egalitarian project
and this egalitarian project usually is
behold into a kind of aesthetic vision
of what society is going to look like in
the future that's very consistent with
what you said victor right once we
create a more equal set of conditions
people's natural talents and capacities
will be able to flourish more uh you
know
uh and this will lead to better
conditions for all more novelty more
creativity etc nietzsche also believes
uh that unleashing certain kinds of
people's agency this is the point the
certo makes will bring about a more
interesting and aesthetically gratifying
kind of society but agency is supposed
to be allocated to a very thin elite at
the top right submission is what's
warranted by everyone else and you can
see why this might actually be more
attractive to some people than the
egalitarian project because the
egalitarian projects the pros supposes
that my agency and my enjoyment of
agency is contingent upon my respecting
your agency and your rights to do what
you wish as well right so there's a
limit to what i can do in this kind of
respect which is you know i have to
respect your fundamental rights and
dignity et cetera uh whereas nietzsche
agency the purview of this elite doesn't
have that kind of limitation for the
cost right uh if i decide that your life
could be meaningfully
used in the pursuit of my artistic
project or vision then so be it right my
artistic project trumps your right to
life trumps your life to the expression
of your own agency because your duty is
to submit to the member of this elite
right that has a better understanding of
what our aesthetic future should look
like uh and what's really i think
important to note is how closely this
maps the most interesting elements of
reactionary thought going all the way
back to somebody like joseph de mestra
right because again there's this
tradition or conviction on the part of
the left that a lot of conservative
thinkers are always about constraining
people that's not been the way people
like damastra or schmidt or heidegger uh
or even somebody like josh supernerv
thought about it the way that
reactionary thought typically operates
even down to something like trump is
that if you belong to the right elite
you should have more agency because
you're the one who knows what to do with
that agency uh the problem with the
egalitarians is that they presuppose
that everyone should be entitled to this
when most people just won't know what to
do with this or if they try to exercise
it they're only going to get in the way
of the people who should be allowed to
do what they want because they'll bring
about better results right yeah
can i just probe one thing about what
you were saying
because like when you were talking about
sort of like this relationship between
the aristocratic elite like on kind of a
nichian view and
the lower classes i th maybe i'm wrong
but it felt like you were
maybe
applying more agency to that
situation than there would be because
like wouldn't it be i don't know maybe
like the thought is
would it not be more a more niche in
view that like it's not so much that
there's like agency here in the sense
that there's like people who are just
gonna like
have to submit but more just that they
will because if we allow the good people
to rise to the top then the others will
just be there and it's not so much that
there's there's less agency going on
because it's all based on this like
metaphysics of the will to power
no i'm or is that i mean maybe this is
like a nitpicky point but i guess in my
mind it just like sounded like when you
were saying and i was like
is there that much like are they being
forced down or will they just be down
because they're like they're they're
hurt and like that's a very interesting
question and i think this is actually an
incredibly important tension within the
reactionary tradition as a whole right
because and it's attention they've never
been fully able to resolve right because
there's this presupposition that most
people
don't really possess a yearning for
agency but then the question becomes
well why is it that sometimes socialist
or liberal movements radical movements
can actually motivate them to demand
agency and in these kind of
circumstances the explanation is
typically that they've been corrupted
or they've been compelled to deviate
from their natural disposition
usually by the influence of intoxicating
ideas and intellectuals that promulgate
these kind of intoxicating egalitarian
ideas and this is where i think
nietzsche's thought is at its most
original at least according to lucerto
because one of the things that he points
about out is that in the reactionary
tradition from people like burke to
maestra uh through you know the german
junkers there was this presupposition
that the biggest problem with
enlightenment radicalism was its attack
on christianity and the old scholastic
worldview right because the old
scholastic worldview held that everyone
had its place in god's ordered universe
uh that included you know the presence
at the bottom and the king at the top
and if we just go back to something like
this then everybody will kind of resume
their proper place in the hierarchy and
we won't have a problem right
nietzsche's kind of radicalism comes in
his belief that actually the pro the
difficulty is that the radical
enlightenment philosophers took in some
senses the spirit of christianity and
christian egalitarianism more seriously
than the scholastics did they really
pushed it to its apex
through this conviction that
if all people are equal before god they
should be equal within society
and they might have de-christianized it
but the root of it is in this kind of
christian ethos of the slave morality
right uh so what makes him so
fascinating as a member of the reaction
of tradition is he would say to somebody
like the jordan petersons or joseph de
maestras or
national review types you think that you
can combine christianity and hierarchy
but the reality is as long as you have
christianity and this belief that all
people are equal before god you're going
to have liberals and socialists emerging
who will say we need to take this ethos
more seriously than you're willing to
push it to its logical conclusion and
have a society where all people are
treated equal and that's precisely why
in his mind we need to break
fundamentally from christian moralism
and go back to something
like the antiquarian world view that
privileged things like nobility or
immobility superiority cost uh all the
kind of master moralities that we saw
back then and it's a really interesting
idea which is which is not what
nietzsche would want right like he
because he he doesn't want these to be
like arbitrary right like isn't that i
mean i don't know like jordan do you
think like
like it's not like it seems like one of
the things that maybe nietzsche has in
common with say like a liberal
is like a distaste for what they see as
like arbitrary forms of rule or like
arbitrary like because like for
nietzsche it's all about like the actual
soul that is actually like like living
up to the will to power and like
overcoming
like i don't think he would be
interested in these like kind of like
symbolic like like hierarchies unless
they're actually rooted
in right right yes no i yeah i i agree
with you that nietzsche's you're right
he has in common like one of the reasons
why nietzsche's vision is moderate like
and part of this is because i i don't
think that it's first of all i say i
don't think that it's necessarily wrong
to think of the modern
as intrinsically linked towards an
egalitarian
momentum i would say that it's there's
an egalitarian momentum
that's different than saying it's neces
that it's intrinsically
that it's intrinsically egalitarian but
even that i don't i'm not i don't know
like for me it's it's kind of an open
kind of an open question and and it
depends all on how you define modernity
like it's like one question is if you
think of modernity in terms of a certain
state of the accumulation of knowledge
then
and if you
one has to be persuaded of this but if
you think that at a certain level
a certain level of accumulation of
knowledge a certain level of
civilizational experience and so on
does or ought to teach us
something about
human
equality
but but that's it's not the only way of
looking at what it means to be modern
another another axis i suppose in which
we could define
the modern is in terms of and it's
actually not unlinked to
the idea of knowledge that's that to be
modern is the more modern we are the
more
um control
we're able to exert on our surroundings
and
uh and so forth right and so one of the
ax axes on which i think it's
indisputable that that nietzsche is
modern is that is this idea of um is
this idea of control um and
the ability to exert unprecedented
levels of control
over
um our political projects and it's even
it's kind of interesting because in the
uh because i i
in preparation for reading this book i
reread the birth of tragedy
and one of the things that asserts in
the birth of tragedy um
is um and macerdo has a really great um
actually he's he spends a good deal of
time talking about nietzsche's early
period when he wrote the birth of
tragedy and what need to critique as
optimism he said need to the early
nietzsche
um and i suppose nietzsche all along was
uh took as his target
um optimism
and optimism like is taken in this
context to mean
that it's um
both that it's desirable and i suppose
that it's possible
to create a world which um
is fundamentally
paradise-like
um like like a world where and this is
where the the egalitarian dimension
comes in where everybody
with a common person so to speak
uh lives in a state of happiness and
satisfaction
and
um
and
kind of everybody's desires are um are
fulfilled
and um so in the birth of tragedy
you know nietzsche is is
challenging this uh in part because
um
he
he believes that it's rooted in a in an
error
and the the error goes back to
socrates
and the belief that
knowledge can
like he says something like like
socratism what he calls socratism is the
belief that knowledge is a how do you
how do you say is this right penichaya
is that the right word oh yeah panacea
right that knowledge is like that
basically all of the fundamental
problems which pose themselves to
humanity
can be solved by
knowledge and this is the socratic this
is the naive socratic view right
and sorry i realize that i'm speaking
much i just wanted to add one thing
quickly to that too because right i
think that uh the socratism is one of
the things that he criticizes about the
french revolution right which is again
really fascinating because his claim is
that if you go and look at back at the
works of plato or socrates right
depending on how you want to distinguish
them there is this peace opposition that
knowledge is available to everybody
right and you can think of uh you know
socratic dialogues how he engages with
everybody publicly or you can think of
you know the famous platonic dialogues
where he shows how even the slave is
capable of reasoning a priori about
mathematics right nietzsche at some
point seems to suggest that even there
is the kind of natal form of this
egalitarian form of modernity that
you're talking about that we need to
reject because there's this
presupposition that since everyone is
capable of reasoning uh and reason is
available to all there's no reason to
put people in a kind of privileged
hierarchy with some at the top and
others at the bottom this isn't what the
greek philosophers believed right but
it's one of the reasons you saw them as
being deficient to the kind of
homeric poets who never had this kind of
belief uh that the masses uh were
capable of reasoning in this way
right
yeah yeah and so
so
so nietzsche and in macerto's account
nietzsche um is attacking socratic
optimism which is this belief that
knowledge you know and it's linked to
the idea that when when people
do
when people act against their own
interests for example
uh it's because they're ignorant or you
know nobody does what is bad willingly
you know and basically the more we know
the better we'll be
is
the socratic line right and to this
nietzsche opposes the tragic world view
but what but
it raises this question why does
nietzsche oppose the
the optimistic view is it because he
just is it because he doesn't like it or
does he also believe that there is
something wrong with it in terms of like
that it itself is false and i think at
least nietzsche does say that it is
false knowledge will not actually
solve
all of the problems
um that we have
and
but what happens is
in the his in the course of the
development of western culture the ideal
of knowledge
becomes
more and more
um
prioritized and saturates more and more
levels of the populace until you get to
the point where even
people who don't undertake
this study of things
just you know the common peasants or
whatever you know they also
in the course of the history of the
development of western culture because
it keeps prizing knowledge they
eventually themselves also kind of come
to be fundamentally optimistic
about where knowledge is taking us as a
whole
and
and because knowledge is linked this is
this is just the point that i wanted to
get to nietzsche says that
um
socratic optimism
produces this delusion
that we have limitless power
that we will have limitless power over
our um over our reality and theref you
know and therefore it will be possible
to kind of create
a world where i suppose the masses
and the elite can both be satisfied
right whereas the nietzsche position is
that you can use in a way they can never
be reconciled to the two of them but the
socratic maybe the socratic delusion
is is
that they
that they can be but but what i wanted
to say is though is that that all of
that notwithstanding so on the one hand
nietzsche has this this critique of
knowledge as as power
knowledge is limitless power that will
solve our fundamental problems but on
the other hand i think that you can't
come away from nietzsche without without
concluding that he is very
um
very much wrapped up
in a
[Music]
what fantasy or an idea of of an
unprecedented level of power
over our um
common human future
and and i think that's something which
does not occur you know you never read
in plato or aristotle or something like
that like
the idea of making one common goal for
all of humanity but zerath but nietzsche
says through zerathustra and others
right that the
the question that like what something is
there through like 1001 goals there's
been a thousand and one goals because
there's been a thousand one peoples but
never has it come up the question what
is the goal of humanity
as such right so this this idea that
like it that and part of the reason why
like i think lujan has such
grand ideas is because he's come to
think like we
as a like there has to be a decision
about humanity as a whole
and that also means like we have to we
have to have some sort of plan
for managing humanity as a whole and we
need to find some kind of goal which
humanity as a whole has and that
presupposes
the ability to
um
to have power over humanity as a whole
and then that and that i think he's he's
very he's very modern and um
it you know even in ways that flirt with
what he criticized well it's interesting
because that seems like you're kind of a
putting your finger maybe on attention
which maybe we won't be able to explore
but like you know between knowledge and
power because like if
like because if he's critical that like
knowledge will solve things but he also
wants to like exert this kind of power
uh that humanity can have a unified goal
it's like how do you expect to do that
without knowledge like where is there a
disconnect between like like the
knowledge and the power that's exerted
it's i mean it's anyway that's a side
thing i know matt you've been wanting to
get in here for a while so so jump in no
no because i would frame it in a
slightly different way i agree with
everything that jordan said right and i
think this testifies the kind of
richness of nietzsche's work as
disturbing because it happens to be uh
but i think that the way that he frames
optimism is slightly different right uh
the optimism isn't just the
philosopher's optimism that things are
going to get better
the problem with this kind of optimism
is when it seeps into the mind of joe
the plumber who starts to think that he
is ever going to be intelligent enough
or capable enough to deserve to have
some kind of say in the order of things
right
and the kind of genealogy that lucero
traces nietzsche is making is that this
kind of socratic or platonic impulse
becomes
universalized through christianity and
this expectation that the kingdom of god
is one gay going to belong to everyone
in particular the poor the meek the
suffering the uneducated all the classes
that the romans and the aristocrats left
behind
and while a lot of the metaphysical
trappings of that disappear over the
course of secularization the millennium
goal of christianity to achieve this
kind of utopian society and the
optimistic impression that that gives
doesn't disappear with the enlightenment
right if anything it becomes
radicalized because there's expectation
that we're not going to achieve that in
the next life which still has a kind of
tragic contour to it right uh we're
going to achieve that in the here and
now you know uh and this is most
explicitly manifested uh with socialism
right as it calls it once uh
christianity with the soul of rousseau
uh or christianity with the residue of
rousseau excuse me and the world of
power right uh and what's remarkable
about this kind of genealogical story he
tells is how expansive it is and how
creative uh its understanding of these
interlinkings are
because no one i can think of in the
reactionary tradition
to this day is really audacious enough
to say the problem with these
egalitarian movements isn't that there's
some kind of break from the platonic or
christian tradition it's that they are
the continuity of that tradition
in the here and now
right uh you don't usually see
conservatives saying something like that
or reactionaries right
and what needs nietzsche thoroughly
modern and interesting in this way as
jordan put it it's precisely his
argument that if you're going to try to
have an aristocratic radicalism you
can't try to settle it on these
traditionalists or theological arguments
because it's always going to seed too
much ground to these concedes we need to
either go further back for insight uh to
the kind of pre-socratics uh or we need
to have the courage to invent new forms
of aristocratic radicalism now right uh
that oh very little uh to this
judeo-christian heritage uh and his
contemporary enlightenment form
and wasn't uh lucerto brings up uh in
some place that nietzsche was actively
contemplating means by which the
commercial class
could somehow be incorporated into the
aristocratic class right because he
unders he understood that it wasn't
possible to have
a reversion to a pre-industrial
pre-capitalist society but he found that
the the
the commercial class was crude vulgar
um
had none of the um
had nothing which you know the real
marks of an aristocracy besides possibly
the accumulation steady accumulation of
power so um
[Music]
yeah and i think and i think this
touches actually because i don't i don't
know if i ever i really quite answered
your earlier question victor was about
like what what is the character of this
aristocratic class that that nietzsche
would want and how does it differ
from the aristocratic classes of um
you know previous ages right and and
what you said i think was that you know
doesn't he have this in common
with um
other more modern things with liberals
is that you kind of like that that you
um you want to get rid of arbitrariness
was the word
yes you want to get rid of arbitrariness
yeah and so that nietzsche wanted the
people to be at the top the people who
were worthy
of being at the top right and you know
in some ways it kind of recalls the um
in in the certain know it's right that
nietzsche cites uh plato's republic
approvingly
um
one because of its hierarchical
structure and because of you know
because of
it places a philosopher
um at the top um but and and he doesn't
say this but i would think that
uh
the the mechanism by the sorting
mechanism right like a plate like
plato realizes that well
there's there's there's something called
chance right and that people being
people are being uh
he tries to distinguish between
different uh qualities of soul so to
speak right remember like there's
like there's uh the souls made of like
lead and souls made of silver
right how do we how do we sift through
them and so they have to create
different kinds of games and
competitions
to be able to sift through
which souls like so you might be born
into the laboring class in the republic
but if the mechanism works
that should be detected and then you
should be
carried over up into the um into the
guardian class right where maybe you can
have the educa maybe and then maybe even
become a philosopher and a philosopher
ruler or something like that well i want
to say liserdo does actually trace this
kind of shifting viewpoint uh on
nietzsche's part about who he thinks the
proper aristocracy is going to be and he
devotes a lot of time to it in the book
and i think it's really telling because
it helps not only to periodize nietzsche
but see how his thinking about this
became more radicalized and more
reactionary over time if that's possible
right
simultaneously because the kind of
initial impression that one gets from
lucero's reading of the birth of tragedy
and the early friendship with wagner
right is that nietzsche was a very
innovative german nationalist initially
and in part he was attracted to german
nationalism because he saw it as a kind
of antidote to french uh liberal and
revolutionary ideas right liberte
gallate solidarity and the soto's
reading is that's one of the reasons why
i need to participate in the
franco-prussian war right he saw the
defeat of napoleon iii
and the kind of birth of the german
empire as a moment of response
and victory uh over the forces of
egalitarian liberalism uh and you know
democracy whether that's a good
interpretation of the polling of the
third on nietzsche's part we'll put
aside right uh but the kind of second
period that lesotho traces is again this
more liberal period uh where he seemed
to have become convinced that
german nationalists uh whether wagner or
the kaiser or others weren't up to the
job of creating the kind of fluid
dynamic vigorous aristocracy and
aristocratic ethic that you were talking
about right and it becomes very
attracted to kind of a right-wing
liberalism
that holds that the hierarchy should be
much more open
it should allow the best to rise to the
top there should be a kind of free
expression of ideas at least amongst
those who deserve to have their ideas
freely expressed right
and that'll filter the garbage out as it
were but even in this time period he
points out that nietzsche's liberalism
is always constrained uh to the noble
few right the people who deserve these
kinds of agency not to the majority uh
which makes him very different
um even though somebody like kant right
who's consistently criticized uh for he
consistently criticizes doesn't make him
different by the way than locke though
interestingly enough lucero compares him
to a lot and then there's this third
period where he seems to be convinced
that a kind of right-wing liberalism uh
an attitude of free spirits isn't enough
still because liberalism itself is too
beholden to elements of this christian
ethic
and there we get a bit of ambiguity i
think you're right jordan where it's not
exactly clear what the next thing he was
going to pin his hopes on were it seems
to me that as nietzsche
in his last phase and i think that i
understood missouri to be saying this as
well
um nietzsche becomes progressively more
conciliatory towards
what one might call the the the
barbarian right whereas in the early
nietzsche
like barbarianism is
um
still a negative word or i mean it's not
that uh
i mean i suppose in some sense it was
all it was already there maybe we'll all
skip trying to compare the the different
faces of egypt but there's this really
interesting um passage in beyond good
and evil
where
he talks about um
there has never been a significant
advance
in uh
in
development of the human
type
um or of a human society that didn't
originate with a barbarian class
conquering another class
and there's this really kind of complex
point that he's trying to make and i
hope that i can make it in a way that
is both intelligible and
um
and fair to what he's to what he's
saying because it's it's because it's
it's a disturbing sort of assertion
that um
he says in this passage like the the
kind of the purpose
is to have an aristocracy
that is refined
uh full of people who are individuals
um
and
uh
and he has this concept of the
individual as somebody who is rare
right so if you think of these
characteristics rare
unique
refined
capability of capable of many different
degrees of nuance in your evaluation
like all of these things are not
necessarily qualities that indicate
uh strength
like i mean like you can be unique you
can be
rare you can you can even have
like
people who are extraordinarily sensitive
can have sublime
perception and a sublime capability of
distinguishing
degrees of differences in things right
so like so
so
many of the characteristics which make
up nietzsche's ideal type
are not intrinsically of themselves
connected to
any kind of strength and they might even
be qualities
that more often than not go with
weakness
if you think like to be extraordinarily
sensitive can make you a more
nuanced and subtle thinker but that
could be linked with
being overwhelmed by stimuli and and you
know in fact
not being
strong uh by a certain metric i want to
frame it to some different way because i
think one of the problems is when we
focus exclusively on what kind of
aristocracy would be the one that
nietzsche wants we ignore one of the
kind of major themes that the book
brings up uh two things actually i
should say one of which is the
extraordinary amount of time nietzsche
spends talking about what constitutes
the proper servile class right so lucero
takes a great deal of time thumbing
through
the twilight of the idols one passage
where he talks that talks about a great
deal uh is nietzsche's consistent
criticisms of universal education um so
i'll just read the passage from twilight
the idols because i brought it up uh
where he says the worker was qualified
for military service granted the right
to organize and vote is it any wonder
that the worker today experiences his
own existence as distressing morally
speaking as an injustice but what is
wanted i ask once more if one wants an
end one must also want the means if one
wants slaves then one is a fool if one
educates them to be masters right and
they're sort of points out he's very
blatant here that the part of the
problem is if you try to teach the
people to be educated and to think that
they're entitled to something they're
going to make those kinds of demands you
need to train them to be slaves if you
want to be the kind of proper
aristocratic cost right so one of the
problems again with the early nietzsche
is nationalism
was this
kaiser right policy of trying to educate
the working class so they'd be more
competitive nigeria wanted to have none
of that later on right
and the other thing that i think is
really important to raise isn't just
that nietzsche is fixated not just on
what constitutes the elite but how to
create the right kind of service classes
but is how his fixation on difference
which i think is a really interesting
point in the book
might sound at first like a kind of
proto-post-structuralism in the sense
that he really is very focused on the
differences between people differences
between cultures
and fixates on them in a way that
liberal universalism did not where they
tried to whitewash all this away but
this is i think where nietzsche is
actually in some senses more insightful
or at least more
disturbing than the post-structuralist
because there was always this assumption
in post-structuralism that a knowledge
of human differences is going to make us
more empathetic and hence more
egalitarian right i'll understand your
cultural difference to use you know the
kind of
jizekian point you know i'll see you as
who you truly are and i'll recognize
that i've walked a mile in your shoes
and then i'll care about you and i'll
grant you rights and entitlements and
nietzsche's arguments is that actually
why if you're going to be attentive to
differences should you not be attentive
to the most fundamental difference of
all which is the differences in rank
between people and this notion that the
most fundamental difference is that some
people just aren't work really much
they're stupid boring ignorant
cow-like humans
and some people are just in many ways
infinitely better than that they're
robust free-spirited kinds that's the
fundamental difference between people
and between cultures and so if you want
to focus on human difference you should
fixate on that and it's interesting that
none of the post-structuralist thinkers
ever really tackle to my knowledge at
least this element of difference head-on
probably because it's highly problematic
and it deflates what i would say is the
kind of cryptocantian underpinning to a
lot of their work which is this
assumption that knowledge of difference
is just going to make us more
egalitarian more understanding uh more
receptive to
different modes of being and accepting
them all at once whereas nietzsche's
point is once you realize the
differences between human being you
start to realize that some are trash and
a very few are gold and we should stop
fixating on the trash and focus on the
gold which is not something
that many of us i think find appealing i
think it's monstrous right but it is a
very provocative idea
yeah no and and i agree and and
it's it is it's it is a disturbing
component of his whole project that if
we are going to that he he sees um
if we're if we're going to have this
project of
creating um
he sees the kind of human being that he
wants to create
can't be created
unless
many are
sacrificed
right and you know and
that's even maybe even attention in his
thought right on the one hand he wants
to emphasize
that like you said there are these
there are these uh
differences right and i think i even
actually wrote something like down which
i i think speaking to your point matt
was about this um
that the higher man right nervous says
that aegis is the higher man as quote
other
right and incommensurable that
difference that these different types of
people are actually incommensurable and
you're right that is that's that's a
really important point that you hear in
i guess post structural philosophy today
and even you know i i studied the
emmanuel levinos for a while um
uh he's a very interesting thinker as
well yeah very good and there's very
good reference yeah right and this idea
of the you know the otherness of the
other and there's just an
for incommensurability there is no
adequation between me and the other and
for for nietzsche that is that is in a
way true as well but you're but you're
right that for him incremental ability
doesn't
redound to equality and it's worth
asking why and we have to ask ourselves
why ought why aren't different per se
lead to
an egalitarian
um conclusion right exactly right why
shouldn't i say there are many different
cultures they exist in many different
forms there are many different kinds of
individuals and most of them aren't
worth very much and only a few are you
know uh most things are rocks a few
things are gold you aim for the gold and
the rest gets thrown in the heap right
that that seems to me to be a lot of the
efforts of what he's saying when it
comes to this question of difference
which again as you think you pointed out
very brilliantly hugely different than
the kind of levynosian
ethic that underpins a lot of like say
for instance deriding post-structuralism
when it comes to things like difference
right that if i recognize the difference
in you i'm really respecting your
individuality and i'm going to come to
care more about you as an individual
right
and so but and at the same time it just
seems to sometimes suggest that these
these people of a higher rank
like that they need like that they need
to be tended to right and that and
that's one of the ways in which in which
like you know uh nietzsche spends a lot
of time trying to draw attention to all
of the ways in which different aspects
of reality are actually
um constructed through human activity
and i guess you know and i guess maybe
it's a very thin difference but it is a
difference maybe he he believes that
these superior types they exist no
matter what we do
uh no matter how we arrange society and
i suppose that's in zarathustra right
anybody who thinks differently goes into
the mad house
i want to frame it somewhat different
way though and victor i really am
curious to hear your thoughts about this
because this is the last chapter of the
book which is really fascinating to me
uh because he takes on the question of
the relationship of nietzsche to
post-structuralism and
post-structuralist politics
and he says this is the interesting
thing right the presumption of
post-structuralist was
universalism was inherently tyrannical
because it had this imperial quality to
it so criticizing universalism made
space for a kind of egalitarian politics
of human freedom that wasn't available
before because it allowed people to
will their own kind of identities and
value systems into being right uh but
lucerno's kind of characterization of
nietzsche's philosophy in a nutshell and
his relationship to this is nietzsche
says actually the problem with
universalism is universalism is
inherently egalitarian because it
presupposes that you have to treat
people the same way
and it's only when you have
perspectivism and everything becomes
just about aesthetic ruminations that
you can truly see the higher caliber
people come to the fore
because when we make aesthetic judgments
what we're saying is some things are
more find beautiful and interesting than
others and i don't have to be
accountable to you if you don't
understand that because you just lack
the refinement and taste that i do
right
that seems to be lucerto's take to this
so if anything
he seems to be saying that it's only
when you have these kind of
post-structuralist mentalities that
emerge that difference is supposed to be
at the core of human society that you're
going to start to find really
aristocratic attitudes emerge since
there's no way of
making plain a set of values that all
people can appreciate and so everything
becomes subject to taste
and our sense of who has good taste and
who doesn't
and desoto also points out that this is
the way that nietzsche typically argued
with his political opponents you very
rarely see him dissect immanuel kant or
dissect saying simone or dissect so uh
his usual denunciation of them is i'm
not even going to bother arguing against
you because you don't argue with
somebody who holds to
bad tasteless values like the herd would
hold to
what i'm instead going to do is point
out how ugly and ungainly and how sick a
lot of your voice will just make he'll
just make vague like funny little snarky
comments about like the english and yeah
usually i think he's talking about the
utilitarians often or like like you know
the jonstrom mills and the bentham's and
stuff yeah or even just say the problem
with your value system is it's so boring
right why would you want a boring system
right and i think this also has bearing
on his way he would have appreciated
post-structuralist politics uh because
there's always this presupposition in
post-structuralism and post-modernism
that the reason why it is that we don't
see interesting individualistic people
coming in and willing their own value
systems is you know choose your label
you know hegemony discourse discipline
control
nietzsche would say the reason that you
don't see this happening is people are
fundamentally different
even external to the society that they
have and some people are just going to
be interesting and will creative and
interesting value systems into being and
some people the most people just will
not and his comment to all the foucaults
of the world is why can't you just
accept this why do you presuppose that
there are certain social determinants
that are primarily the basis for so many
people just being ignorant buffoons
when really that's just the iron law of
nature well i mean wouldn't you go
farther and say it's not just
sociological but it's also there might
just be like biological or natural
differences that like you know like
like that are not you know subject to
whatever like because i think isn't that
because isn't like i mean this kind of
brings that there's maybe like this kind
of like metaphysical difference or
something between like the egalitarian
and the and the non-egalitarian where
it's like uh
you know i think the egalitarian premise
of like the post-structuralist
nietzscheans is like
depends on this idea that like ever all
these social structures that lead to
inequality are contingent and like could
be different
right and like it's just about like it's
those things
whereas like i think the more like
nietzsche and i guess like truer denisha
would be like no no people just are that
way and there's nothing we can do about
it like there's just gonna be
differences and some people are gonna be
better and it's gonna be only the few
who are gonna be like really the ones
worth
uh anything
well i think he he varies back and forth
uh because you know nietzsche was a
moody guy as we all [ __ ] know right
his girlfriend dumped him he had all
those nasty things to say about
girlfriend there's no girlfriend well
you know like yeah he's flirting with
that
but anyway it seems to me that what
friend zone his friend zone
what seems to be interesting about him
is at some points he actually worries
that the kind of socialist and liberal
project will be achieved that it is
possible to actually create this kind of
environment and what's interesting is
it's going to be
exactly what foucault and duluth et
cetera all dread which is that this
leveling impact is going to mean all
people are going to be the same the herd
mentality is going to rise to the fore
and what we're going to see is crass
values at the epicenter of our
civilization very massive exactly
average person is exactly right
and
he says it might be possible to actually
achieve this in fact he sometimes seems
to worry that that's the direction that
we're going in and his argument is
very much in a kind of positive
prostructus line we need a reassertion
of difference but the most important
reassertion of difference is again this
difference in the quality of human
beings predicated on their ability to
create interesting novel and exciting
values uh which will never and can never
be the mass right
you know what you're saying is making me
think of some stuff i've been
encountering in my own research because
i've been reading a lot of the
post-structuralists sort of like like
egalitarian radical democrats and like i
don't know
i still haven't been able to but i'm
having this sort of like broader insight
into things and like i don't know about
you guys but like i like sometimes i'll
like capture a thread and like i'm
pulling at it so it's not fully
articulated yet but i'm kind of
but basically like the claim i'm
starting to come to is
that actually like the these
post-structuralists
or a lot of a lot of like what we might
broadly associate with sort of like
post-structural egalitarians i mean it's
bigger than that and that's like a
contestable term but but like in general
that like that overall thrust like
i think that like at the core is like an
unacknowledged or aristocratic attitude
among them and like what the reason i
think that
is because like often the solutions that
they have for things are like so for
example the radical democrats are like
you know
we need to we can get rid of these like
you know these structures these
institutions that are just like pushing
us into this mass society and like this
kind of fake democratic because it's
like a racing difference right again
difference comes up for them like we
need to let the difference come out and
like combat itself but we also need to
make sure that this political order
these political contests don't devolve
into like these antagonisms that are
like disorder
but like the problem i'm kind of
looking at in my research is like well
how do you do that they don't really
talk about like
how to have these like
political contests that like proceed
where like difference is really
acknowledged
but they don't devolve into like
violence and instability
and like often the answer that they all
have is to like
almost what i'm seeing as like a sort of
civic virtuous attitude or like a kind
of intellectual activity where you kind
of like realize
that like everybody else's belief
systems are contingent and you're
contingent
and it's like this kind of mental
acrobatics it's almost like learning
these post-structuralist insights about
like the aporia it's kind of like you
have to develop these attitudes and like
dwell in this kind of like you know
undecidability and i guess like
and i even noticed this i don't know if
you guys heard about this book that came
out i was reading a review about it the
right to sex
by like oh i've heard of it yeah and
it's she's this feminist author who's
like kind of like trying to dwell in
this like uncomfortable space between
like you know more conservative ideas of
sexuality and like her solution again is
to like dwell in this like you know this
contingency in this weird space and like
i don't know this isn't really like well
articulated yet but like i guess i kind
of think that
like the ability to do that
like requires
like quite a bit of effort like to come
to that realization to like understand i
mean i don't know we all studied
philosophy for a long time to like have
those insights to know even what that
means
it's difficult
um and like i guess like sometimes it
seems like they just like assume anybody
can have those insights and that's gonna
solve our societal problems just like
get in touch with this but i guess like
i think it implies a kind of i don't
know this is like maybe this is like
half baked but like i think it like
requires
like
quite a like more effort than they think
and and i think it it implies
that like
knowing that having those insights is
better but because i think only a few
people can actually have those insights
in their proper way it implies an
aristocracy without knowing it because
it's like only these like knowledge
holders can figure out these
post-structuralist insights but they
kind of like assume anybody can
um and they don't really think about
like the difficulty i don't know
i don't know if that makes sense but
so just a victory point i think they are
absolutely right that the kind of
underpinning ethos uh or disposition in
a lot of post-structuralist politics uh
is this idea of what the pseudo call is
i'll just go with him because we're
talking about him uh democratic
individualism and you can see this with
this idea of rhizomatic thinking uh that
we talked about a little while ago as
well right that
more democracy is going to breed more
interesting kinds of individualism
because it creates a space for
difference uh to flourish
and ultimately it's going to create a
more intriguing society and what's
interesting about this is that i do
think a lot of post-structuralists are
attracted to this because they are
egalitarians in a certain sense but they
also just think frankly to go to your
point that's going to be a more
interesting society because society as
it is right now is just really boring
right and we want one that's more
dynamic more intriguing uh more
characterized by
big novelty novelties forms of novelty
emerging right uh and a lot of this is
inspired by a kind of nietzsche and
disposition uh but to go back to
lucerto's kind of point i think you
would say that this nietzsche would
actually say
democratic society rhizomatic thinking
is exactly the problem right uh we have
too much horizontal forms of
organization right now this
presupposition that everyone should be
allowed to contribute uh is the big
reason why we see things like crass
value systems emerging and so what we
need is a reassertion of much more
horizontal forms
of organizing society if you're going to
actually have interesting kinds of
politics and interesting kinds of
projects emerge because if you have
rhizomatic or democratic society what
you're gonna have is not individualism
uh it's you're gonna have a lot of
people watching reality tv at night and
eventually electing reality tv type
presidents
right um you know there's a kind of
gesture for you right yeah uh and i
personally don't think that he's right
about that i do actually believe that a
kind of democratic individualism is
correct but i do think that as leftists
we do have to acknowledge that sometimes
if we create the material conditions for
everyone to flourish they're not just
going to necessarily commit that to some
grand project of self-expression a lot
of people are going to commit themselves
to living reasonably comfortable lives
that are comparatively sedentary and we
have to accept that that's absolutely
fine because what's important isn't
creating an interesting society it's
creating a just society where
everybody's able to live a life of
flourishing
and the two i think can go together but
they're not necessarily going to at all
instances and i'm content with that
personally
but i don't think a lot of kind of
post-structuralist democratic
individuals are to them the excitement
and the kind of hyper novelty is the big
appeal of this and if they don't get it
i think they're going to be really
disappointed in all instances they're
going to be disappointed yeah and i'll
just quickly respond before but like
yeah and i think that's right and and uh
i do think that there's kind of a
fetishization of uh of kind of like
novelty on the post structuralist left a
little bit uh like as we've sort of
talked about in on previous episodes and
um
yeah and i i mean for me like a lot of
my influence is coming from
like i'm really interested in
subjectivity the question of
subjectivity and like mira laponte and
phenomenology and psychoanalysis and i
guess like my
understanding of human subjectivity from
those
makes me think that that like having
those insights those these novel
insights this rhizomatic thinking
having it
like be in like most people is just
doesn't make sense to me i think it's
like actually takes a lot of effort for
people to come to those kinds of
insights and i don't think it's a
realistic expectation
that we can have a social transformation
where everyone becomes like a rhizomatic
thinker or something like that i mean
certainly not enough people to like
actually have the kind of transformation
that they want or at least i'm i'm a
very big skeptic about that uh to a
certain extent so i and i just think
that like
by
like i think that they they are
unwilling unknowingly becoming a kind of
aristocrat because they kind of like
look down sometimes unknowingly on
people who like aren't thinking that way
and or something or they'll blame like i
don't know social structures or like
capitalism on people like not thinking
that way and i don't know i think that's
all
i'm skeptical about all that yeah i
agree i'm just going to say this last
thing uh my i'm committed i'm a
committed enough liberal socialist to
say that if we create the material
conditions for your flourishing and you
decide you want to smoke weed masturbate
uh and play league of legends all day
and not engage in any higher life
project than that all [ __ ] power to
you you know what i mean uh i will get
you a subscription for league of legends
myself okay if you decide you want to
commit yourself to a more interesting
project than that i think many people
will but i absolutely do not require it
uh to hold to my political yeah i agree
with that anyway that's okay all right
jordan what do you think
what are your final thoughts about the
book you don't have to respond to all
that nonsense we were talking about but
um what do you got well no i mean i i
think in some ways this what you're
talking about really gets to the heart
of the question because i think we're
getting you're getting onto the i think
the basic tension which is nietzsche's
obsession
and that's the
the tension between
the many and uh and the few right plato
had the one in the many nietzsche has
the many and the few
i think and um
you know and it i i i guess i do regard
it as a worthy question
like um
like you were just saying now right like
it's um
what's more important is that people
flourish and that some people find
society interesting but what if some
people can't flourish unless they find
society interesting and then what
grounds do they have to believe in the
idea of justice that you're preaching
so
you so those are you know and um and
what you said earlier like victor like
um
okay so marx you know even marx seemed
to imagine a world where we could read
can't in the evening right and
so
i don't have an answer for this problem
but i think that it that it's
and i think that nietzsche's extreme and
uh and i don't follow him on it um
but um
i i personally don't think that that uh
the question of the
the quality i guess it also we have to
ask what do we mean by flourishing as
well like this and when we call it
something interesting right when we talk
about society being interesting like
that can be a way of uh trivializing it
and we have to we'd have to be more
precise about what we mean and we have
to be more precise about what it means
for people to be uh dissatisfied with
that but i guess my response to what
you're saying is i don't necessarily
regard it as by itself
a flaw for somebody to have aristocratic
sentiments of a client right the
question is about integrating those
sentiments in with justice but that's
also what is justice and so i don't have
any answer to any of that i just i just
but i think that i think that you guys
touched
our problems today jordan that's what we
brought you in everybody every solution
you need to come up with it but i think
that you you're you're in your exchange
just now touched on a bunch of like of
live questions about like you know and
things about which it doesn't
unfortunately we maybe were more naive
in the past that there was a simple
answer to i mean we're not even in the
position to satisfy it's not even
obvious we're in the position to satisfy
everybody on the basically material
level i mean maybe theoretically it's
possible but like we're not it doesn't
seem that we're able to actually
organize like it doesn't actually seem
practically possible at the moment so we
might be so far from getting maybe so
ahead of ourselves yeah you know but i
think that nietzsche was need to you
know in his privilege and uh
had this question like right like about
um
what about the satisfaction of the
people who don't
fit in
and if you weren't if you were that way
it's it's
very acceptable still to uh even the
most left-wing figures right so uh it's
strange it's strange how that question
can become a radically right-wing
question and that's the fact and that's
the fascination of nietzsche i think and
i think and i think masera did a good
job of
of um
honing in on
all of these
these ultimately barbaric and awful
things that nietzsche said but in a way
that wasn't like this um
he did he doesn't
he doesn't just sit there castigate
nietzsche and say this is an awful
person even at some point says somewhere
like if we're gonna save nietzsche i
don't know what he meant but like you
know like he meant like if we're gonna
have the proper evaluation of him we
have to be honest about this political
difference but he doesn't he doesn't um
i don't know he leaves a lot he needs a
lot of work for us to do
in terms of what is the value of this
legacy i think and i think that's the
strength of the book that it's just it's
very kind of a cold this is what he said
look at it yourself and you know
more conversations to be had later well
that's a great that's a great point to
end on i think and uh great book you
know lots of lots of um
lots of thoughts lots of puzzles
remaining and and hopefully we can have
you back on and i'll mention too like
you know obviously listeners
check out the liserdo book we'll we'll
put a link in the description and i
think i'll also mention that one of the
reasons we're kind of doing this is
because matt has been working on this
edited volume too another one of his
edited volumes now coming out this time
on nietzsche as an aristocratic thinker
is that right or his critiques of
liberalism and socialism was that the
angle
yeah we're kind of looking at
nietzsche's politics uh jordan's
contributing exactly
more
pieces by him uh take a look at that
well whenever it comes out like you know
that it'll be a while away and i'm sure
i mean i'm sure since you know we
will use the podcast to promote it at
some point so at the very least i'm sure
jordan will come back on when we can do
do a discussion about like the the
edited volume as well but but hopefully
sooner than that so uh thanks everyone
and that was that was a good discussion
thanks you guys
i appreciate it
[Music]